diese aufnahmen machen traurig wenn
karpfen springt im todeskampf mehrmals
hintereinander aus dem wasser aber er
hat keine chance verändert wie etwa 3000
andere fische in der saale bei bernburg
ein angler film die szene und sagt zu
bild das habe er in 20 jahren noch nie
gesehen und dann der schock im wasser
entdeckt der 32-jährige hunderte tote
fische die ursache für das massensterben
so eine defekte rohrleitung seien aus
der amerikanische flüssigkeit austritt
das umweltamt und die
wasserschutzpolizei ermitteln nun gerade
erst gab es in der oder ein großes
fischsterben grund waren giftige
chemikalien
ob das hier auch zutrifft ist bislang
unklar die wasserproben werden derzeit
noch ausgewertet
[Musik]